when you have down time would you do to
drum up that next job hmm well I try not
to have any down time at all but it
could mean that in that downtime I'm
just doing a lot of like promotional
gigs freelance gigs things that are
going to be bringing the money
production gigs things like that so you
know you're you're focusing on that like
okay but yeah in the back of your mind
is it okay old wins where's that max
acting project so i think it's usually
about for me anyway right now without
having the representation and having an
agent that you're good on constantly
going on auditions because I don't
audition much like I've had a handful of
auditions this year and auditions is a
numbers game you know so the more you
audition the more likely you are to book
something and if you're not auditioning
a whole lot you're not you know so um so
I've had to just kind of embrace the way
it's happened for me so far and the way
it's happened is relationships like
really chance strange weird awesome
occurrences you know from robot chicken
came through Friendster and Deadwood
came from being a background and then
the horror film i co-produced the
director reached out to me on Facebook
and Space Command now came from Mark's
table lists and legendary is coming from
another Facebook email so it's been very
organic and I've had to just trust that
that organic mess will keep happening I
mean of course there's been times not so
much right now but you know I've got you
get your marketing tools in place you
know you've got your business cards
you've got your postcards you know every
couple every three months or so send
down a postcard to that whole contact
list no not just some random post card
thing you know have something to say
like hey I just updated my website
have you checked on this episode or hey
I booked this so postcards are they like
less non-obtrusive way to keep yourself
in front of somebody's face because hey
it's sitting on our desk and you know
who knows maybe it just happened across
their desk at the same time that a
casting was hot bending for instance at
the group acts of friends that I talked
about in the class rules group we had
started a commercial drops so basically
during our downtime we had team leads
and we had people we had a list and we
had organized and we had a list of all
the commercial casting directors in this
town we split it up into three areas the
valley Hollywood and the west side and
we assign team so we collect the gas
money and your team went and trying to
figure out like hey is this commercial
office receptacle to us just coming in
and dropping off some headshots eight
out of ten of them were some of them no
access you can't get in it's gated it's
guarded whatever or bad energy like you
know you got dirty book or something
like that but eight out of ten of them
half of the basket on their gas can
you're like hands it okay if I drop
these head shots but be walking out the
doors you say it so that you know that
you're not trying to stay and have a
conversation with them and I had to tell
them are like yeah sure and so the one
awesome story from that is um we had
class later that night and we always
shared good news was the first thing we
did in class for sure good news and so
one of our friends one of the guys in
classes I got a call right before I came
for an audition at such and such as
office and I don't think I've ever
submitted to them me and my partner
looked at each other we went we chopped
your head shot off there earlier today I
like the whole class was just like no so
um staying proactive you know I'm
trusting that it's organic and that the
right people will find me but also
staying proactive and having you know in
blogging and and and keeping that social
media thing going what I've been doing
like with Twitter for instances I'll go
through or I'll find people or I'll see
somebody retweet like just for instance
there was a gentleman I just saw
somebody retweet and he you know he's a
director over at fear Ned and a few
other horror magazines and you know and
I love the horror genre so I followed
him well then I saw him talking in here
apparently he's from Philly so I was
like hey I'm from Philly to and he
responded he's like how you doin you
know and like and then he followed me
you know and so it's it's constantly
reaching out to people who you feel
lined with in some way and then
organically and authentically clicking
like on their things and communicating
and talking to them and reaching out to
them when you have a project that you
think would line up with something that
they're doing because then you know the
next thing you know they've got you know
three projects away like only yeah yeah
lets you know and so it's it's a really
all about relationships like it really
truly is and having you know having your
tools ready and updating your stuff and
you know recently updated my hosting
demo you know a lot of the stuff on
there was was older and I had all the
new stuff from the red carpets with D
and people like that that I wanted to
add because it had primarily been a rock
and roll demo it was a all rock and roll
musician so it was fine by me but this
past year I've got an interview a lot
more actors and other people in the
industry sounds like I we got it we got
to mix this in so that you know people
can see this and go yeah she can stand
on a stage and interview Ozzy Osbourne
but she can also sit down and get
dressed up and hang out talk to Oprah or
the fire team or Gore get it get bright
kid friendly family entire video hos
with fire chief yeah yeah so I think I
think that's the answer in a nutshell is
just continuing to build the
relationships and continuing to work on
on yourself you know whatever that may
be you know whether it's you know
through health and fitness and yoga
classes or whether it's taking up a
hobby and like getting like you said
getting your mind away from the industry
go take a painting class or a pottery
class or something cool like that put
your hands in the dirt put your hands in
the dirt
you